You've probably seen these smooth SAS
animations online, and by mastering
these SAS animations, you can make a
crazy amount of money. And today, we're
going to create one about notion. So,
this is what we're going to create. If
you ever try to organize your work, you
know how messy it gets. Notes in one
app, tasks in another, ideas scattered
everywhere. Notion fixes that by
bringing everything into one place. Now,
let's jump into it. Now, we're here in
After Effects. So, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a new
composition, and I'm going to make it 25
frames per second. duration. Uh,
something like this should be fine. And
then I'm going to keep that the same.
You can also use the preset 4K. Uh,
that's a really nice preset. Press okay.
And we have our comp. I'm going to
import our voice over. And the voice
over
is here. There we go. If you want the
voice over, you can just download it
down below. And you can also download
the project file and see the full deep
dive of this notion tutorial. And you
can do so by joining the full stack
editor club. Link is down below. Uh,
join if you want. and then I'll see you
there. Now, let's uh drag this voice
over in the comp. And there we go. And
here we have the script. I'm going to
first focus on scene one, two, and
three. And in the full stack editor
club, I will go also into the scene four
and scene five. And of course, the
inspiration beforehand. First, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go create a
new solid. So, let's go to layer, new
solid. And I want to make this not fully
white, a bit of like a a creme cranle, a
nice like warm white. I'm thinking of
something like this. Press okay. Press
okay. And then I'm going to import this
video. Uh I created this using AI. So
let's press open. I generated the image
using midjourney and then I animated it
using Hickfield. Now if you don't want
to generate this yourself, you can just
download it down below. Let's drag that
in. And as you can see, it's not the
right color. Also, not the right size.
So, first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to scale it up a bit. Press S for
scale. And I'm going to set my quality
to full so I can at least see it a bit
how it looks like. And I'm just going to
change the screen mode here on the side
to multiply. That will make the white
transparent and blend with the
background. I do still see some edges
here. And to get rid of that, we just
need to add a levels. So, let's go to
the effects and presets and add a
levels. There we go. And then we can
just drag it a bit uh so it's a bit more
contrasty. I want that anyway also on
the left side because I want it to be a
bit more black. I I like it to have it a
bit gray, but something like this should
work. Now, the first animation I'm just
going to use scale and make it so it
goes from this to 100%. And I also need
to offset the timing a bit because uh I
think this needs to happen a bit more
soon. Let's do it something like this.
And I'm going to easy ease this so it's
nice and smooth. Let's go to the graph
editor and let's select the last key
frame and let's make it so it rams in.
Going to set it to quarter. So quickly
preview it. I think it all happens a bit
too slow. So right click time, enable
time remapping. And then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to move this last key
frame just a bit more towards the
beginning. Then drag this scale out.
Okay, this is perfect. I might even fade
it in so we have a nice transition in
the beginning. Nice. And what I want to
do is basically have a paper flying into
the screen basically as a transition.
And to do so, we need to have a paper
that is a bit similar. And to do or to
create a paper like this, it's really
simple. I'm just going to go to the pen
tool and I'm just going to draw a shape
uh with that color and with this stroke.
So, let's go to the stroke and select
this color. And then let's select the
fill and select the background color.
Press okay. And then I'm just going to
go to the pen tool and I'm going to draw
a really like jaggedy paper. Uh maybe
like have it rounded a bit. Something
like this. But then also I'm going to
just like make a quite rough shape of a
paper. And like always, you can also
adjust this later on, but that's fine.
We can just have it maybe something like
this. It looks like has a bit of a a
butt. Maybe we have to adjust this a bit
so it's a bit harsher. Let's go. We have
a paper and that's nice. And we don't
even have to animate this in. And the
other papers appear quite harsh. Uh so
we can do the same with this one. So
just hold alt and then left bracket or
uh on Windows alt on Mac also alt uh but
it's called option. Um and then of
course on the shape layer. So basically
this this just appears like that. And
then basically what I want to do is I
want this to this paper to move towards
the screen. Now of course we can make it
3D and stuff like that. However we can
also add a CC page turn. And with this
we can make this awesome animation. And
as you can see, we can make it fold a
bit. And by the way, you can just search
for CC page turn in the effects and
presets to edit. We do want to change
some uh values. So the back opacity I
want to set it to 100%. And then there's
also this ugly ass light on it. I don't
want that. So the light direction I'm
just going to set to zero or align it so
it doesn't add any light to it. Maybe a
bit more to the right. There we go. Now
I'm going to turn this uh controls to
classic UI. Uh select the past turn
again. And where's my controller? It's
here. So, we can control it a bit more.
Nice. And then I can also change the
fold direction. I want to have it folded
like this. And now that we have our
shape and page turn, what I'm going to
do is I'm going to just pre-ompose it.
And we do this by hitting command shift
C or control shift C on Windows. Okay.
And then I'm going to link it again to
the animated video. And let's go into
the shape. And then we have to animate
it here. And to do so, I'm just going to
go into the fold position and set a key
frame for that classic UI so we can
easily change it. And then we can just
move this around. Let's set this to
quarter. So it will be a bit more quick.
So I'm just going to start here and then
go a few seconds further and then just
fold it around like a pancake. Maybe
something like this. Uh let's see if we
need to change the fold radius also. I
think I like it when the radius is a bit
bigger. makes it look a bit more
realistic. And the fault direction I'm
going to change a bit so it's also a bit
more you can see the fold a bit better.
Then the light direction. Let's change
that so it's not as harsh. Just a tiny
bit. Maybe on 57. That works. So let's
see. Looks nice, but it is a bit harsh.
So let's press U on our keyboard and hit
F9 on that last key frame just to easy
ease it a bit. Maybe even a bit more.
the beginning. I don't mind if it goes a
bit quick. Yeah, that works. That works
really nice. Maybe we can even drag this
out a bit. This is more smooth. Perfect.
Very nice. Cool. Now, we go back to our
comp and it will look a bit ugly, but we
need we now have to add some animation
to it. So, let's see. It starts around
here. Let's press P for position. Set a
key frame. Uh, go a bit further. Let's
move it like below here. We also have to
scale it up, but let's do that later.
And then maybe here back here. Let's
move it to the center again. And I'm
going to go into my convert vertex tool.
If you don't see this, click and hold
your mouse down on the pen tool. And
then we're going to make a nice circle.
Let's make it a bit like this. That will
make it look a bit more realistic, a bit
more organic. So it falls like that.
Let's see. Maybe I want to even move
this a bit. So it's even more organic.
We can also rotate it. So let's press R
for rotation. and P for position. And we
already had that. S for scale. Set.
Press U on our keyboard. And let's move
these to the beginning in the
beginninging. And then uh let's see what
we can do here. Maybe make this one F9
so it's a bit more smooth. And then we
want to end it here around here. Scale
it by a ton. I want it to fill the whole
screen. Scale and position. Something
like this. And I want this scale to
happen a bit later. So we can just hit
F9 on our keyboard on both key frames
too. But we can go to the graph editor
and then uh just adjust it a bit. So
this happens a bit later. Uh so it's
like more like this. It's already cool
in my opinion. The end it goes a bit
weird with the position and the scale.
We can fix that with a null object or we
can just go into the position and then
let's see if we can maybe adjust the key
framing here a bit. There's a bit of a
dip here. So let's see if we can move it
this better. Very nice. However, uh as
you might notice, uh this goes quite
smooth comparing to the rest of the
comp. And that is because we have a bit
of like posterized time, which basically
is like a low frames per second. I
didn't do that on purpose on the
animation. That's just how it is.
However, we can also add that to this
animation. And to do so, I'm just going
to go to my effects and presets and add
a posterized time on this. And then
maybe set this to 15. That should work.
maybe even lower, maybe even 10, which
looks all right. However, because of the
animation and the page fold effect, this
the frames don't align well. And that is
mainly because the animation is still
smooth, but the page fold isn't. So,
what we're going to do is going to go to
layer, new adjustment layer, and then
we're going to go to this posterized
time effect and just cut it and paste it
on that adjustment layer. Now, it will
also affect the video down below, which
actually is not bad cuz it will blend it
a bit better. I think it looks really
cool. The only thing that our layer is a
bit too sharp in my opinion. So, last
thing what I'm going to do is I'm going
to add a mosaic effect to this. So,
basically just go to the effects and
presets and add a mosaic. And this is
basically an effect normally to create
like a pixelated effect. You just want
to set this quite high. Maybe even 500
by 500. Even more,000 by,000 already
works better. Uh with and without. With
without really sharp with blends a bit
more. Now maybe this is a bit too much,
but also when it goes bigger, it should
be Let's see. Yeah, I do want to
increase it even more cuz I don't want
it to be super unsharp when it's uh
zoomed in like this. I think this could
work. Let's see. As you can see, it
blends so much better. It's a small
effect, but without it and with it, you
can see the difference, uh, it just
blends better with the background. Now,
we can also upscale the video. That is
also a solution. However, um, this is
just an easy way to blend objects. And
then I want to have a text here, how
messy it gets. And I don't want to have
everything uh with a posterized time.
So, I'm just going to make sure that all
the layers from now on are above that
posterized time. Let's go to the
horizontal type tool or just the text
tool. And then uh let's click here how
messy it gets. San Francisco Pro medium.
That's fine. Let's change the fill to
almost black, but like a off black.
Something like this. Press okay. Let's
make this really nice and big. And let's
center this. Now, normally I like smooth
animations, but with notion, I think a
bit of like a harsher effect can work
well. So, no motion blur. Maybe also not
really like feathered masks, which is a
challenge, but let's see. For the first
one, I want to have the words just pop
up out of thin air. Uh, so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to add a mask
to this. So, let's go to the rectangle
tool and then make this mask really nice
and white. And I'm doing this because uh
we can then later on reuse this. So,
let's drag this down to something like
here. And if you want to move your mask
around, you can hold spacebar to move it
around. um to have it something like
this. Just make sure the whole object is
in there. There we go. And now let's go
to the animate and then position. And
then I want to go into the range
selector and go into advanced and then
change the uh based on to words because
I just want to animate the words. Now
what I want to do is change the position
to be below the mask as you can see.
Just make sure they are all disappeared.
I'm going to change the shape to ramp up
and then the ease low to 100%. And then
I'm going to go to the offset and key
frame the offset. So the offset goes
from minus 100 to a bit further down to
100. Now let's close this text and press
U to see the key frames. And let's align
this a bit better. Uh and I might want
to start it already here. Something
around here. Just so it's like
continuous movement, right? Maybe a bit
more quick. Nice.
And that's it for scene one. So let's go
to scene two. And in scene two, we have
notes in one app, task in another ID
scattered everywhere. And I'm thinking
to have a fake notes UI and then maybe a
task UI and transition between these two
scenes. And to transition between these
two scenes, I'm going to use a technique
that a lot of these size explainers use.
And that is by going to layer, new, no
object. Link this text to this no
object. And then I'm going to choose a
movement. In this case, I'm going to
press P for position, set a key frame,
and then I'm going to go a bit further,
and I'm just going to make it quite
high. I would say maybe even around
here. So, there's quite a lot of
movement. Let's drag this out to the
beginning. And then select these key
frames, hit F9, go into the graph
editor, and make sure that this graph is
really spiked. Just like this. So,
there's like a nice peak. Just something
like this. And then, uh, we're just
going to cut this off right here. Hit
alt right bracket so it goes like this.
Then we're going to make a note tap. And
to make a note tap, I'm just going to go
to the rounded rectangle tool. The fill
and stroke are fine. I want to change
the stroke to be a bit more thin.
Probably uh five. And I'm also going to
use a trick later on. You don't even
have to turn the fill on. Uh but if it's
the same background color, that's also
totally fine. So now we can just draw a
shape. And I'm just going to make it
sort of like a phone shape. Probably
something like this. I want to increase
the roundness by a lot and maybe also
increase the stroke with a bit to
something like this. There we go. Now
I'm going to right click layer styles
and then do another stroke. And in this
stroke I'm going to change the color to
white. And then set the size to maybe
like 15 or something. Let's quickly
check this in full quality. And as you
can see, we have this nice black stroke
and then this white stroke. And this
looks really cool in my opinion. I've
seen this in quite a few designs, so
that's why. Now, let's center this using
the align tool. So, it's nicely in the
center. And then I'm just going to go to
the text tool and type something like my
notes. Let's make this way smaller. And
let's of course align this in the
center. There we go. Maybe make this
text even smaller. Uh then I'm going to
go to the text tool again and I'm going
to make a paragraph text. So, I'm just
going to click and drag. Let me paste
this text. There we go. Uh, also make
sure that this is aligned to the left.
And maybe make this a bit bigger. Uh, I
also have these titles here that need to
be bold. So, let's make those bold. And
then let's make this bold, too. And then
this bolt, too. Let's see what this
looks like. Pretty nice. I think it's a
bit too small even. Uh, let's quickly
check. This was 49 pixels. So, I just
want to make sure that this is not much
more than that. So, maybe 39. And then
maybe I'm going to add a quick button.
So let's add the ellipse tool. Make sure
nothing is selected. And the fill. I'm
going to set the same color as this
stroke. And the stroke I'm going to turn
off. So let's click on stroke none. And
then I'm going to create a quick like
plus button here in the bottom right. So
hold shift just to add a bit of visual
style to this. Otherwise it's a bit
boring in my opinion. Let's align this
nicely. Quick alignment tip. I see a lot
of people they put it like uh just like
this or something. It looks horrible
because the padding on the right is not
the same as the bottom. And also give it
room to breathe. So put it somewhere
around here. If you then zoom out, you
can see that also looks really clean.
Now, of course, I want a quick plus
button on this. So let's just go to the
text tool and type a plus and make the
fill color the same as here. Or I can
actually make it white. Let's see what
this looks like if it's white. make it a
bit bigger. Of course, um it's quite
thick. So, let's change this to maybe
medium. And then let's move this. I
think that looks pretty clean. Although,
as you can see, or maybe you don't see,
but this plus is now quite huge. I think
it's uh nicer if it's a bit more like
regular. And then just a bit more thin
or a bit smaller somewhere like this.
Align the anchor point in the center.
You can use a tool like motion tools or
you can hold command or control and
double click on the pen behind tool.
That will center the anchor point too.
Now I'm going to link this to the shape
and we have a nice scene already. I
think this looks cool. Now of course we
still need to animate it. And to animate
it what I'm going to do is quite simple.
I'm going to make sure that the text is
just linked to this uh shape which is
the iPhone or the phone. Um, so just
parent them. This button I'm also going
to parent to the shape. Uh, so it's all
linked to the shape. And then just make
sure that the animation of the null is
done. So press U on your keyboard to see
the position of this null. And make sure
you're behind this last key frame. And
if you then link this to this null and
we go towards the front, you will see
that this already has a cool animation.
Now the only thing we have to do is
basically make sure that this is cut in.
So let's select all of these, hit alt
left bracket, and we already have a cool
animation. If we now just quickly play
this back, you will see this really cool
match cut, which we want. However, I do
think it's still a bit boring. And to
make it a bit less boring, I'm going to
animate the text, too. Uh maybe I'm
going to just keep this my notes or just
fade that in. So let's press T for
transparency. uh set a key frame and
make sure that it goes from zero to 100.
And then for the text, I'm just going to
go into the text. I'm going to go
animate opacity
and then uh just set the opacity to
zero. And then go into the range
selector going into advanced and uh
change the based on to lines and shape
ramp up ease 100%. And then change the
offset to minus 100. Set a key frame. Go
a bit further till here or something.
and then set it to 100. And this will
add a nice animation to the text. I do
think that the animation can go a bit
smoother. All in all, so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to close this
and I'm just going to drag this key
frame out of this null. Do make sure
that the peak is still here. So for
example, if we move it here, we can do
that. But we just need to go into the
graph editor and adjust the peak a bit
because we want the most movement to
have the match cut basically.
This is already nice. And then I'm going
to change the notes to be even longer.
Press U on that paragraph. Let's drag
this out a bit. Somewhere like here. We
want the button to pop up. So let's
press S for scale on that shape layer.
Set a key frame. Drag this out. Set this
to zero. Press R for rotation. Set a key
frame. Press U to see the key frames.
Drag this to the right. And then maybe
set this to minus 45. Then I'm going to
make sure that it's a bit bigger here.
So go a few key frames before the scale
is 100%. And let's set this to
five. Then I'm going to select all of
the key frames, hit F9 on my keyboard,
go into the graph editor, and then maybe
drag these last two key key frames out a
bit. and maybe make the scale a bit
smoother at the end. Select that last
key frame. Just like this. This comes in
a bit too late. So, let's move this. So,
it's notes in one app and then tasks in
another. And to create the tasks app,
I'm going to basically just select the
shape layer and also the paragraph and
the notes. I'm going to reuse that. So,
I'm going to duplicate this. Command D
on Mac. Control D on Windows. Let's drag
this above all of the other layers. And
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to unlink this shape layer for now. So
let's just set this to none. And then
open the shape layer by pressing S. And
then I'm going to make it really big
because I want to have this as a like a
scaled up version. I think that will
look awesome. Maybe something like this.
And now it looks really ugly. But we're
going to use a transition again. And
since this is unlin, we can just go and
turn this off for now, just so we can
see it a bit better. Then I'm going to
go to layer, new null object, and I'm
going to use a new null. And it's
important because I want to have an
overlap of animation. I already want to
start this animation when this hasn't
ended yet. And that will make it really
nice and smooth. So let's go press P for
position and set a key frame around
here. Then I want to link this null to
this new null that we created. Go a bit
further to maybe around here. And then
move it all the way to the left. And
actually quite far cuz I want to have
quite a lot of movement. And maybe even
drag this out to around here. Select
both of these key frames. Hit F9 on our
keyboard. And we can always adjust this
a bit. But let's go into the graph
editor and make this nice and spiky. So,
it's like notes in one app, tasks in
another. Nice. And again, what we're
going to do is the same thing. Just go
behind this last key frame. And now we
can link all of these by just linking
this shape layer to this null. We can
link it to the null one because that's
basically our main null. And now it
should have a nice movement. I might
even move it a bit more to the left so
it's aligned like this. We go. Now again
on the peak which should be around here
doesn't have to be perfect. We can just
select all of these layers and hit alt
left bracket and then with the old
layers that we have here we need to hit
alt right bracket so they're cut off. So
right on the moment they're cut off and
this comes in. So it's like
that's in one app tasks in another. Now
of course this is not animated and we
need to change this into a task
management app. So, let's change the
text first to tasks and then we need to
change this into a task management and
that doesn't have to be crazy. I found
this inspiration on dribble and I'm
going to recreate it somewhat. So, I am
going to steal some elements here. Uh,
what makes a task management tool? So,
we already have the title. I'm not going
to do anything with that. Maybe I'm
going to change the text to like today's
tasks. press U on our keyboard to make
sure that this animation starts at the
right point and then this text uh I am
going to use but for example with so for
example what we can do here is do the
dishes or you know what let's keep it in
editing so like sort out footage let's
change this to regular it doesn't really
make sense that it's still a paragraph
but it's fine for now I'm going to add
the text today under that. Let's select
that text, make that a bit less dark.
So, maybe something like this. And we
can also make that a bit smaller. And we
can even add a bit more spacing to that.
Something like that. Nice. Now, I'm
going to go to the rounded rectangle
tool. Uh, change the fill to white.
Press okay. Stroke set to none. And
then, I'm just going to draw a quick
box. Something like this. There we go.
Roundness, nice and rounded. Probably
something like 55. Make sure that this
is below our text. And let's align this
a bit nicer. So, we need to move this a
bit up. Let's see what this looks like.
I think it looks clean. I think it looks
cool. It looks like a a to-do app. Maybe
we have to make it even a bit bigger by
going to the size and doing it like
this. And as you can see, we now have
the same padding here on the left of
this and also on the left of this. And
then also on the top and bottom. So, it
just looks really nice to the eyes.
Maybe I'm going to select them both.
Move them down a tiny bit. Just like
that. And now we just need like a nice
button. Now, of course, after this, do
make sure that this is parented to this
null, too. If we don't do that, then you
will see that it looks really ugly
because we didn't parent this shape yet.
It's fine if you animate it behind the
key frame or add it behind the key
frame. Uh so, let's go a bit more to the
front and maybe I'm going to reuse that
circle that we made. So, let's just uh
grab that circle. Where is it? Uh, I
think it's here. I'm just going to
duplicate that. Bloop. There we go. And
then move this up. And then make sure
it's unlin. Let's go a bit towards here.
And let's move this. And we already have
this shape. I think it's actually nice
in terms of the uh size. Let's drag it
out so it's a bit longer. Um, let's move
this to a nice point. Maybe around here.
Press S for scale. And make sure that
you're on one of these key frames. You
can just click on this left arrow, click
on the scale and then we can just scale
it up. And what this does is basically
scaling all the key frames. Uh so you
don't have to go bit by bit per key
frame and then change it. The only thing
you do have to take into account it will
also change the first key frame which
should be always on zero. So let's
change that. Let's see what this looks
like first.
I think it's clean. Nice. Uh now we just
need uh like a check mark. And to add a
check mark, you can download an icon, of
course, or you can just create one. A
check mark is not too crazy. We can just
go to the uh pen tool and just uh make
sure the fill is set to none and the
stroke is set to white. And then the
stroke width is set to like 5 pixels or
something. And then let's just draw
something like this. You can hold shift
to make it like nice and straight. Um so
we have something like this. Maybe I'm
going to select this by going to V. Make
it a bit smaller. You can also adjust
the way it's set up. Don't make it like
this. Don't make it like this. Just make
it like this. There we go. Nice. Maybe a
bit too thin. So, let's make it a bit
thicker. Let's change this to full so we
can see what this will look like. Looks
nice. And then you can keep it or that
it's uh quite harsh, I would say, on the
on the lines. You can also go into the
shape, go into contents, shape stroke,
and then change the butt cap to round
cap. And that will make it rounded. It's
more like a stylistic choice if you
prefer that. I do prefer that in this
case. I think it's nicer. Nice. I just
want to move it a bit so it's aligned a
bit better. And I'm going to link that
to this shape. I'm just going to quickly
see what this animation look like. Also,
with the rotation, I'm not sure if that
works as well. I do think it can work
well. Let's press U on that text. Since
we already animated that before, we can
just uh drag that out. So, it's animated
already. Everything is animated now
except the box. Now we can of course
move that in or we can just add opacity
to this. Sometimes it can be really
easy. You don't have to overdo it. So
press T for transparency opacity and
let's fade this in. So it like fades in
nicely from zero to 100. Now what I want
to do basically of course link this and
uh also link this to the null. So it's
all nicely linked. Again make sure
you're after that key frame of that
null. So let's see where is the key
frame? It's here. Uh, so we're nicely
after it. So we can just link this one
and this one. I always just check the
parenting. As you can see, these ones
still say none. So that means they still
need to be parented. And we're going to
parent them to the null one. Uh, just to
make sure. You don't have to, but it's
just easier in terms of workflow to
always link it to the same null and then
make new nulls for the other animation
later on. We quickly preview this. As
you can see, we already have this cool
animation. Uh the only thing I would say
is we need a few more tasks. And to do
so, of course, really simple, guys. We
can just make sure these layers are cut
off nicely. So, hold alt left bracket.
And then we can literally just select
all of these layers and duplicate them.
Except the phone and accept the today's
task. So, just these four layers.
Duplicate. Drag them up. Drag them up.
And then, uh just offset them a bit. And
then, uh we can just move them down
holding shift and then the arrow keys.
Make sure it's nicely aligned. Just
going to go a bit further so we can see
the spacing. Probably something like
this. And then we can even add another
one to make it realistic. Move that out
a bit. Try to get the same padding. Now,
of course, I want to change the text to,
I don't know, edit base edit. And then
it goes to ID scattered everywhere. What
I want to do is basically have one task
in the middle and then maybe have like
IDs popping from the back or something.
But for this to happen, we do have to
have these uh or have one in the center.
So the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to go into the null, press P
for position, and make sure that this
null at least aligns everything in the
center. And you can also go to the title
action save to make it uh a bit easier
to align. As you can see, we have some
lines where we can align this to the
center, too. There we go. Then I'm going
to go to layer, new null object. Again,
link this to the null object. Press P
for position. Press S for scale because
we're also going to animate the scale.
Press U on your keyboard. And let's drag
these key frames a bit more to the left
again to have a bit of overlap. Then
let's go a bit later and let's move
this. Then I'm going to change this to
maybe export. Export something like
that. And I'm also going to scale it
down. We probably have to reposition it.
Uh again, probably something like this.
There we go. Then of course, select
them. Uh hit F9 on your keyboard. Go
into the graph editor and make a nice
peak of both the key frames peak content
here. Very good. Very nice. This all
goes a bit too quick. I want it to
happen a bit more late like a bit later.
So we can just select these key frames,
move them a bit. Cool. Nice. And for
this next animation then, like I said, I
want to have maybe like postit appear
from this uh export edit. I might even
change this text to like um find ids or
something. Find ids. I think that makes
more sense. And then when this happens,
we can or cut it off or we can fade it
out. In this case, uh I might just fade
it out and also fade the background
because we have had the background the
same the whole time and I think it could
be cool to have it different now. So,
let's select the the phone, press C for
transparency, set a key frame. Uh, I
want to fade out the rest. So, I want to
set a key frame for today's tasks. And
let's see. And also this, uh, I want to
fade out everything except defined IDs.
And the last, uh, two shapes. So, let's
select these, press T for transparency,
set a key frame. For the others, we
might have to just click that button.
Then, we go a bit further till here. And
then, I'm just going to fade this out.
So it all fades out while when this
animation happens. As you can see, a
fade out can be really smooth. Also,
might want to easy ease the one for the
phone to make it a bit more smooth. And
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to add a bounce to this. So press S for
scale. I'm going to make sure that these
are all linked to this shape. So let's
uh link this find ids today also to the
shape. And then also
this shape which is this circle. We also
need to link that to this shape. So if
we scale this now, it all scales with
it. And we can set a key frame. And then
I just want it to uh bounce. So
basically when it's here, I want to have
it go to maybe like 70. Then we might
not even have to scale it down too much
with the other animation. Something like
this. And then hold alt, click on that
stopwatch, and paste this expression,
which you can also find down below. So
we move this a bit closer. Make sure
this happens a bit earlier. Now, let's
change the background. And I'm just
going to do that by hitting layer, new
solid. And then let's make this almost
fully black. Uh, just something like
this. Okay. And then let's press T for
transparency. Set a key frame. And then,
of course, fade this in. Just a simple
fade in when this happens. And now I
just want to have some postits pop up.
And for this I have uh this paper
texture, which you can also download
below. And I'm going to use this for the
postits. Now, I like to keep it simple.
So, I'm just going to use the texture
itself and just add a mask to this. You
can also add a shape and alphamat and
stuff like that, but I I think we can
just keep it easy and keep it simple.
And then to change the color, we can
just add a tint and levels to this. So,
maybe the levels first and then the
tint. And you can just search these in
your effects and presets. And let's
first use the levels to add a bit of
more contrast to this. So just drag the
right slider and the left slider to
something like this. And then change the
white in the tint to a color you like.
So for example, we can change that to
yellow. I'm going to do something like
this. Okay. And we can then also adjust
the levels a bit so it's a bit less
heavy. There we go. And that's our first
postit. And as you can see, this small
like a little texture here that really
adds to it uh to make it really
realistic. And then I'm just going to
add the text um idea. Let's make this a
written font. Make it a bit like darker
gray. And let's make it a bit more big.
Let's turn the quality to full just to
see what this will look like. Idea.
Create a personal
brand. Let's change the paragraph size
to auto. And then let's make this a bit
smaller. And I'm going to align it in
the center, too. So, just like that.
It's not perfect, but that's totally
fine. We can now just make sure that
these are linked to each other. So, the
text is linked to the texture. I'm going
to select them both and move them below.
There we go. Below. There we go. And
then, of course, we also have to link
lastly, where is it? The texture to the
null one. So, everything is nicely
linked. And now to animate it, I just
want to have them like pop out. And what
I've seen a lot is that they're not
fully like scaled down. So it's
basically you scale it from uh for
example, now it's at 158. We just set a
key frame. You go a bit to the front and
you scale it down a bit. Just like that.
Press P for position. Set a key frame.
And then we move it a bit to here. Press
R for rotation. Set a key frame. Drag
this out really far. and then maybe
rotate it a bit. And then basically what
it does if we now select them both and
we hit alt left bracket to cut them off.
It basically adds this animation to it.
As you can see where it already is
scaled so you don't scale it from zero.
Now of course we need to uh nicely
animate this and like now it looks
really ugly. So maybe have to move it a
bit to here have the rotation so it goes
more like this. And then we need to add
a few of these elements. What I also
want to do, uh, what you might notice is
that there's no shadow behind this. I
also want like a nice drop shadow around
this. And of course, we need a few more
IDs. But let's start with the easing.
So, I'm just going to select all of
them, hit F9 on my keyboard, and then
also make sure that the position is
nicely eased. So, I'm just going to drag
this all the way to the right. And then
the rotation, the same thing. Uh, I'm
also going to make sure that this is
like nicely ease. So, it just moves like
this. Maybe even have the rotation just
set to zero. You can even cut it off a
bit later and move it a bit more to the
front. So, it's like this. And then, uh,
next part is just really simple.
Duplicating, rinse, and repeat. Changing
the position a bit. And that's it. So,
I'm also going to do that. Uh, I'm just
going to duplicate this once. Drag this
above it. Make sure to just select the
texture. or press P for position so we
can see where the key frame is and we
can move this for example uh to here. We
can also change the scale a bit. So
press S for scale. Uh make sure it's
scaled down so it's not the same size.
And then we can change the color to
maybe like off red. And then we can
change the text to like ID film uh
video. Film a YouTube video. Nice. Press
R for rotation on the texture. And uh
now I want to for example change this so
it's a bit more like this. And now I'm
just going to do that a few more times.
There you go. We have some notes here.
Uh to top it off, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to add a soft glow around
this. Maybe in this like yellowish
color. And to do so I'm going to just
use the dark orange solid. And I'm going
to add a four color gradient to this.
And uh just make sure all the uh colors
are set to the dark grayish. Maybe just
copy this over. But you can also use the
color pinpoint tool. And then only the
last one which is this yellow. Going to
make a bit more like whitish. There we
go. Just like that. Press okay. Now
let's change this point to the center.
And for that I'm just going to add a
gradient ramp to this. And then let's
change the ramp to radial ramp. Uh the
start color I'm going to set to like a
yellowish. Something like this. Press
okay. And the end color, of course, to
like that dark black that we had before.
Something like this. Okay. Now, let's
change the point to the center. Uh we
can also just type that in. It's 1920 by
1080. And then I'm going to change the
ramp scatter to really high. And that
will add this cool uh noise effect to
this. That will also make sure there's
less of a bending effect happening. I
think we can set this to maybe like 80
or something. That should be enough.
There we go. Now this is still a bit
ugly. Uh we can change that by changing
the end ramp to be a bit more uh spread
out. And then what we can do is of
course we can blend it with the original
which automatically will make it less
bright. And it will just add a bit of a
glow to it. It doesn't have to be much.
And then I'm going to even key frame it.
So set a key frame where at the start
this is set to 100% and then later on it
will basically go up. Maybe we can set
this even a bit lower to 70 so it's even
a bit more visible. And like I said, it
will add this cool glow effect to it.
Now, let's go to the next scene. And
that is notion fixes that by bringing
everything into one place. So, of
course, we're going to have to
transition from here. Uh we can make a
smooth transition from this window. We
can change this into a notion. So, let's
just do that. And to do so, we can just
press S for scale. However, uh there is
an expression on this. So if we would
now scale this, it would keep bouncing.
Uh so unfortunately what we have to do
is create a new null uh and just use the
NLES to animate it in. And we already
have this null three. So we can just go
to layer, new null object, link this
null three to the null 4, and press S
for scale. And I actually want to make
sure, so let's press U on the null 3
that again we start this key frame
already before. And that will make it so
again we have continuous movement. Let's
scale this up. And again we can cut this
uh cut these off. And for the shape of
course key frame the size, not the
scale. I can't say that enough. Let's
drag this out to the front. And then
let's make this unlin. And then I'm
going to make it bigger so it's more of
a notion UI. And then this needs to be
aligned with the null. Um what I'm going
to do is I'm going to select the null
key frames. Hit F9 on the keyboard and
let's key frame these first. Make sure
that they're nicely spiked again. Just
like that. This looks really lame now.
And that is because this needs to go a
bit later. And again, we can literally
already select all of these layers. Um,
except of course this shape and of
course this text because I want to fade
out the text. Press T for opacity. Drag
that out. And then go a bit further.
Let's fade that out. And then uh of
course this needs to be nice and easy
east. And then all of the other layers
we can just literally cut off. So let's
see. That's I think all of these. Yes.
Alt right bracket. Something like that.
Let's quickly preview this. Basically
what you will see is that it will go
like this. A bit too late in my opinion.
I think it needs to go a bit further.
And in this case you can see that a
harsh cut like this can also work
against you. That it doesn't work as
nicely. And that is because this center
piece will stay the same. So in this
case, we tried it, didn't look great. So
what we do is we just fade it out. And
then we can or fade out all of the
elements or we can just create a new uh
solid, which I prefer to do because it's
just a bit easier. And I want to change
the background. Anyway, we're going to a
new scene. So let's just grab that solid
that we had before, the pale orange
solid. Command D. Drag that up.
There we go. And uh then just make sure
that it's on top of all the other
layers. Press T for transparency. Set a
key frame. And then we can fade that in.
So let's fade that in. Make sure it's
starts at zero. So maybe around here. So
it goes like we maybe a bit earlier. So
it's done before the transition. Notion
fixes that. Really clean. The only thing
of course is uh this is ugly because
these uh also need to fade out. We can
just fade those out together with the
find IDs today. Maybe we can move those
a bit more to the left. Select both of
these. T for transparency. Set a key
frame. Wee. Make sure to drag these to
the left. There we go. So, they fade out
together with the text and the
background. And then we have a clean
slate to start from. Now, I'm going to
even uh we have the shape of course like
popping out. I'm even going to make that
bounce. And and you can use an
expression for this on the uh scale or
on the size. However, you can also
easily just copy and paste this uh key
frame, make it a bit bigger. So, it
basically is going to be a bit too big
and then size down. And now we just need
to recreate a bit of a notion uh notion
UI. And I want to have it minimalistic.
Notion is already really minimalistic,
but a lot of these tasks are not. So,
what I always like to do is squint my
eyes a bit to see a bit like which
elements pop out and then use those
elements because you don't have to
recreate the whole UI if it just looks a
bit like it. It will save a lot of time.
Now that we set this up, let's go to the
next scene. And in this next scene, we
have the notion fixes that by bringing
everything into one place. And for that,
I'm just going to add the notion logo,
have that popup, and then have the
notion UI popup. So, I have the notion
logo here. Uh, let's start out with that
first. So, I'm just going to press S for
scale, set a key frame, and make sure
that that pops up around here. So, zero,
and then 200. And then I'm going to add
a expression. Uh, and you can copy that,
of course, down below just to make it
bounce nicely. And once it's around
here, then I'm going to move this with a
P. Set a P for position. Move this to
the left probably even more. And then I
want the text notion to appear. notion
no motion a bit bigger. There we go.
Maybe move this a bit. Make sure this is
nicely aligned. And to align something
really well, you can always uh make sure
nothing is selected. Uh make a quick
shape the same size as the text and the
logo combined and then align it in the
center just to quickly see how far we're
off. We're a bit off. So that means that
we can both move these uh a bit to the
left. And it doesn't have to be perfect,
but uh this does look a bit nicer. And
then for the animation, I'm not going to
do anything crazy. I'm just going to add
a opacity animation and then add also a
rotation. And then also add a position.
And then basically what I'm going to do
is I'm going to rotate it a tiny bit,
move the position a bit down, and have
the opacity set to zero. And then to
animate it, like always, just go into
the range selector. Just change the
shape to ramp up ease low 100%. And then
let's key frame the offset. So it goes
from zero to 100. Something like that.
Now, of course, I also want to easy ease
the position of the notion logo. And
then make that really nice and smooth. A
nice spiky curve. Maybe drag that out a
bit. And then move the notion below the
logo. Cool. But I do want to have a bit
of delay between this. So let's drag
this position out. and make sure the
notion logo appears a bit later.
And then from here, uh, we can link them
to each other, but I'm just going to
create a new null just for these two.
Uh, so we can basically move them both.
I press S for scale, P for position, U
to see the key frame. Drag them out.
Maybe start it around here. So it's like
we And then basically what I want to do
is make sure that this is like a nice
logo on top of this notion page.
probably even a bit smaller. Then I'm
going to add a new shape to this just to
make the UI. So let's add the fill.
Change the fill to something like this,
but then a bit darker. Just like this.
Okay. Stroke I'm going to turn off.
Okay. And then I'm just going to draw it
just like this. Maybe it's even a bit
too dark. Um we can change that. Let's
go into the fill. Maybe make it a bit
lighter. There we go. Then of course
select this and use the trackmat tool.
So it's trackmatted to the background on
top of my head. That's shape layer 11.
Uh, it should be fine. Let's see. Let's
select it quickly. Now, shape layer 10.
Uh, you can also just uh trackmat it
using the pick wave tool. Shape layer
10. Bloop. Turn shape layer 10 back on.
And there we go. We have a sidebar. Now,
what I also noticed in terms of the UI,
uh, the background now blends in a bit.
Um, so I might just add a really soft
drop shadow to it. And this is basically
like the Apple style drop shadow. to do.
So, I'm just going to duplicate the uh
shape layer. Then, I'm going to add the
effect drop shadow. Double click. And
then we can turn the shadow only on.
Let's make sure that this is below our
shape layer. And then we just have to
adjust this a bit. So, let's set this to
180. Uh distance quite high. Something
like this. And then softness really
high. There we go. And then opacity
really low. Just has to be a tiny bit.
Just so we have a bit of separation.
Maybe 10 to maybe 15%. Let's see what
this looks like. Nice and soft. That's
how we like it. Perfect. Now, I also
want to fade this in because otherwise
it's going to be active all the time.
Uh, and that's nice because now we
separated it. Uh, we can even rename
this to drop shadow. So, we know this is
our drop shadow because if we don't do
that, then it will also be active here.
And then, uh, we might see that. As you
can see, looks a bit stupid. We also
have to change this, but we can do that
later on. So, what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to go to where I want it
active, which is around here. I think
here it actually looks quite cool. So, I
might just move these opacities so it's
like not visible here, but it is visible
later on. So, I might just change the
opacity of the drop shadow so it's a bit
like it turns on here. Nice. Perfect.
Really, really cool. I do notice that
this logo can even go a bit smaller in
my opinion. Um, I like it. I like it
small P. There we go. Nice. Looks cool
already in my opinion. Now, we need to
create a sidebar. And to create the
sidebar, I'm just going to add some text
to it. So, let's just go to the text
tool. I'm not even going to use the
paragraph. I'm just going to click here
and then like editor limited. Then the
next one is quick find all updates
settings and members. This already looks
quite ugly. So, let's select the whole
uh left paragraph. I'm going to make it
way smaller. And then we also have to uh
change the styling of some of the text.
Um that word workspace for example, we
want that smaller uh just like the
shared uh and private. And I want to
make sure that those are the same font
size. So basically you just make it 36
for example. Then you remember that.
Then let's also make this one 36. Then
we can make this editor limited uh bolt.
I'm going to make the quick find
settings and members a bit like a
lighter gray. Something like this. And
I'm going to copy this hex code because
we can then paste that on the rest.
Maybe even lighter. I think like can go
as far as this. And then the workspace
I'm going to make even lighter. And I'm
going to copy this hex code and paste
that on the shared and private. There we
go. This already looks cool. However, we
do have to change a few things. Uh the
spacing between the text is definitely
too tight. Uh, so we can just select the
whole thing and then increase the
spacing between it. Then we can even
scale it down by pressing S on your
keyboard to make it even more neat. And
then I can align it a bit. And
officially uh the notion UI, you would
have to uh like overlay it and put this
in the top left. But sometimes you can
just keep it how it is. Or for example,
we officially need to select this text
and add a bit of paragraph indent to
have it like this and then add some
emojis. I'm not going to do that because
adding those emojis will just take a lot
of time. Now we can already use the same
trackmat uh that we just had of the
shape layer and that is to shape layer
10. And then what I want to do is
basically animate this um and of course
also link it. So let's select these both
and let's link those also to shape layer
10. And then uh let's animate this. I'm
going to even link the text to shape
layer 13. Uh and then press P for
position. Set a key frame. And then
let's see. We basically want to move
this in once this logo goes down. So
maybe somewhere around here. We just
move it from the left. And I'm not done
yet cuz I was also thinking maybe we can
animate the text. So let's go into the
text animate the position and the add
property opacity. Basically, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to make it so
it moves a bit from the left, not too
much. Something like this. And I'm going
to set the range selector in the
advanced tab on lines. So basically,
they move in by bit by bit. So based on
lines again, shape ramp up ease high on
100%. And then key frame the offset. So
let's set this to minus 100. Bit more to
the front. And then here to 100. And
then of course the opacity. set it to
zero. So it starts with a zero and it
fades in nicely. It's a really nice and
smooth animation as you can see. Now the
only thing we have to do is of course
easy ease the shape. So select the key
frames, F9 and easy ease them. So now
it's like like this. That notion
animation is still horrible. We also
need to smooth that out. Just like that.
Nice, nice, nice. And maybe we can also
add a slow scale to this. That could
also work. Now I have like a cool house
emoji. Uh I mean notion does work with a
lot of emojis. Let's align this nicely.
Something around here. Very good. Very
nice. And then we can just add another
text. Let's add a title here. Um editor
editor home. And let's make that dorm
room. I also want to make it nice and
big and bold. Something like that. There
we go. Now in terms of alignment, I want
to of course align this with the uh
home. So it's something like this. Then
of course we want to animate this too.
And to animate this I'm going to just
add a to animate this I'm just going to
use the same animation that we have on
the notion text logo. So we can just
open that and copy and paste the
animator. There we go. Press U on our
keyboard and let's move this so the
timing is a bit better. Let's make this
emoji pop. And we can use the same skill
animation for that. So let's copy that
and paste that on the logo or the not
the logo but on the house ploop. So it
bounces nicely. Let's quickly play this
back in quarter.
Now one thing I want to do is I want to
make sure that this logo or not this
logo but this emoji is nice and high
res. It's definitely not. Now so we can
actually use a detail preserving upscale
for this. Uh let's double click on that.
And then we can upscale it by quite a
lot. Change the alpha to detail
preserving. And uh if you turn this on
and off, there's a huge difference. And
you can also use a AI upscaler for this.
But for now, this could work. And now
I'm going to scale it down. And by doing
so, we can just later on make it uh a
bit bigger. Cuz from here, I actually
want to transition into the next
animation. And for this next part, I'm
not going to do a crazy transition. I'm
just going to make it snap into place.
So, we'll just do a layer new null. Make
sure it's above our previous null. So,
layer new null. Bloop. And I'm going to
press S for scale and P for position.
And what we're going to do is we're
going to go one key frame further by
holding command or control on Windows
and then right arrow key. Press S for
scale and then scale it up by a lot.
Now, nothing happens. And that is
because we didn't link everything yet.
And we do have to do that. And to do so,
we just need to make sure that
everything above here is linked,
especially the things that are not
linked yet. Uh, so as you can see, the
editor, house, that kind of stuff. Uh,
I'm just going to select that. I see
here another null. I'm also going to
select that. And I think that's
basically it. We can just, uh, parent
these now to the null that we just
created. Or we can even do it nicer
where we just link it to null one. And
because null one is linked to null two,
null three, null four, null five. You
get the point. Let's link null four to
null six that we created. And then it
should work where it's like where if we
now go back to where we were, we scale
it in. And as you can see, it will move
with everything. And now we can also
move it right here. And we can then have
a slow movement from left to right.
Press P for position. And then let's
move it slowly. Just like that. So what
happens now? It snaps into place. Just
like that. Maybe drag this out a bit so
it's a bit slower. And now I want to
create a quick UI. And to do that, I'm
just going to create a rounded
rectangle. And we don't have to animate
this per se. We can fade them in. Uh so
it doesn't have to be crazy. However,
what I want to do is for example have
like a income thingy and then uh maybe
like task task of this week. So let's
just create the first shape. Make sure
that it's rounded. Let's increase the
roundness. And I'm just going to make it
white. And I'm just going to add a soft
drop shadow to it. Right click, layer
styles, drop shadow. And just make sure
that that drop shadow is really nice and
soft. So increase the size, the distance
to zero. Now the angle on 90°. And then
let's increase the distance a bit. So
it's like bit like floating. Size
opacity really low. Really low. Just
like that. Just so it pops off the
screen a bit. As you can see, looks
cool. And to make it easy for myself,
I'm just going to duplicate this text.
Uh because everything is linked to this.
So, we can just make it a bit easier.
Change this to regular. And then, uh,
income. Let's make this smaller. There
we go. I'm going to add another line to
this. And then do plus 54. Wait, 5475.
Let's select that and make that a bit
lighter and a bit smaller. Select both
of the text. Decrease that line height.
There we go. And then a few bars. Um,
we're just going to draw some bars. I'm
going to fill that with the color gray.
And I'm also going to make it nicely
rounded. Not too rounded, but something
like this. There we go. And then I'm
just going to duplicate this a few
times. Make it smaller. I I think Oh,
unlink it. Um, what we can even do is
just keep it like this. Duplicate it.
Duplicate it. One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven. Six, seven. I might
even fit um seven of these. That would
be nice. There we go. Uh to make it
nicely aligned, I'm just going to select
them all and then I'm just going to go
to my align and then you can change this
to uh distribute layers and center it.
Then at least the spacing between it
will be the same. Uh we still have to
align it a bit, but I think actually
this could work. Uh it looks quite nice
in my opinion. I think they're a bit too
dark. So maybe just select all of them
and change the fill to be a bit lighter.
Something like this. That makes all the
difference. And then, of course, I also
want to animate them. And to animate
them, I'm going to select them all.
Properties. Select all of the
rectangles. We can just set a key frame
for this. And then, let's see. Set a key
frame. Also, parent these to the null.
Um, we actually have to parent this all.
Let's see. All of this stuff. Ideally,
you want to do the animation later on. I
did it the wrong way around. And then if
we now move our cursor, you will see
that they're off off sync. and they that
you have to align it. It's it's a bit
unhandy. So I would definitely recommend
to do that later on, but for now it's
fine. I'm going to link this again to
our null one. It's easy to remember.
Same with this shape. This also needs to
go to null one. Uh let's go back to our
shape layers. Press U on our keyboard.
We still have the sizing. Uh basically
what I want to do is that once this is
here, these are all sized up. So, let's
just uh what we're going to do is I'm
just going to set the second value to
zero on all of them. Just like that. I'm
missing one. This one also to zero.
There we go. So, they all go like This
looks a bit lame uh because it's not
ease. And also, I want to have them
offset. So, basically, you just uh right
click, key frame assistant, easy ease.
And if you have motion tools, you can
just make it nice and smooth. And you
can also offset them. Uh so, basically,
the um first one goes like this. So,
there's a bit of offset in there. You
can also do this manually by just
selecting them and then moving them
around or moving them one frame. Uh,
let's see what this looks like now. Very
nice. Now, what I do want to do is, of
course, fade this in because I don't
want it to be visible here yet. So, we
do need to change the timing a bit. Uh,
and to do so, just go to this income,
press U on our keyboard. Make sure that
this starts at least later on. And then
this shape. I'm just going to fade in.
So, press T for opacity or transparency.
And then drag this to zero. Moving the
key frame out first. And then it will
just fade in just like that. Nice. So,
we have our income. Uh, I don't like the
animation of the income and the text. I
think it's a bit too much. So, let's
open this text and then the animator. As
you can see, the position is set quite
high. I want to change that. The
rotation I don't want to move anyway.
And then uh the or the position I'm just
going to move. So, it's has just less
animation. So, it's just like smooth
animation.
And then we just need one more and that
is a task list or something like that.
And to do so, we can just duplicate
things. For example, the shape and the
text. However, I don't want to uh
duplicate these shapes. I don't need
those. So, I'm just going to duplicate
these two. There we go. Drag them up so
it's nicely ordered. And we can move
these to the right. And then we can
change this to today. Today to do maybe
change this to Monday mat Monday. And
then for the um things, I just want like
a list of things. And u I'm just going
to make a simple ellipse. Make sure
nothing is selected. And let's just draw
it. Hold shift to make sure it's
proportional. Uh the fill I'm going to
turn off. And then uh the stroke I am
going to turn on. And I'm going to make
that so it's like a bit like a darker
gray but not too dark. Something like
that. It's like a nice circle. I can
make them pop up. I can trim the paths
whatever you want. Whatever you prefer.
I might just copy the scale key frame
again from our uh home emoji. There we
go. Now, of course, we need to change
the key frames and stuff like that. Uh,
so we of course need to make sure this
is linked to the null one. And then we
can just quickly check how this looks
like or what this looks like. I think
the to-do and this one needs to be
offseted a bit. Uh, as you can see, so
we can just drag this a bit. These come
in a bit later. We have quite a lot of
time here. So, we can just drag that
out. Let's maybe set this to 22. We have
one. and then uh the next to-do, then
the next to-do, and then maybe one more
in terms of spacing. I also think they
can also all be a bit smaller. So, let's
just select them all and make them a
tiny bit smaller. That will make it a
bit more luxurious. Then, they have to
move a bit more to the left to be
aligned. Then, we just need to have some
to-dos. We can, of course, offset them
too. Uh or by using Moser tools or we
can just uh manually drag them uh drag
them out. So, just like this. One, two.
three. So they go like nice. We can add
a text here. Might just duplicate this
text that we already have. That will
save some time. And then we can type in
uh headit for client. And then maybe
like finish headit for client. Of
course, also with this text, I don't
want it to be this big. I think it's way
too big. So this can be a bit smaller.
Maybe the same size as Monday. Let's see
what is this. Uh 24.1. So we can just
select this. and also typed that in
24.1. And then I also like this
grayness. I think that also works for a
title like this. So we can color pick
that. Um maybe a bit too dark or too
light. Looks clean. And then let's align
this. Make sure there's like nice uh
there spacing is nice. And then open the
text. And then let's go into the
animator. Um what I want to do is let's
see. go into the range selector and
change go to advanced and change the um
based on to words because I don't want
to have too much of those character
animations. I think character animations
are nice for like titles, but I don't
want to overdo it and have too much of
those character animations. I might
actually change it also with the income.
Um, this is like a nice big title. And
then in terms of the animation, I think
it's too much if everything has the
character animation. So, let's change
this to words. Let's change this one
also to words. And then, uh, it's all a
bit more clean. We just need to come up
with three more to-dos. And that is
create a personal brand. Nice small
tasks, tangible. All right. Picture is
aligned nicely. And then maybe offset
the timing a bit. And then you get
something like this. If you want to see
the full deep dive, then do join the
full stack editor club. You also get the
project file. You also get access to all
the other deep dives and also access to
a amazing community of editors that all
want to help you out. I would say, but
I'm really biased, but the best editing
community in the world. Of course, don't
forget to subscribe. We're almost at the
100K subs. I'm really looking forward to
that. I'm also going to give something
away when I'm at the 100K subs. Then I
want to thank you for watching. Thanks
for all the support. And then I'll see
you next time. Bye-bye.